[Music]
hello and welcome to the reason
Roundtable I'm Peter suderman filling in
for Matt Welch who got a lead on an
incredible stash of Tops baseball cards
from 1978 just couldn't make it today
today I'm joined by my usual Roundtable
panelists Catherine mengue Ward and Nick
Gillespie as well as special guest Eric
Bame everyone say hello howdy hey happy
Monday Vader
happy Monday indeed that's right so
today we're going to start with a
segment we'll call cop ouch segment
titles are sometimes silly but this is
serious we are going to talk about
police violence and what if anything
we've learned since the police killing
of George Floyd in 2020 as you may
recall Floyd's killing was captured on
cell phone video by an onlooker that
video showed a white police officer
fatally kneeling on Floyd's neck for
about nine minutes Floyd's death sparked
waves of protests riots and at times
violence in cities during the pandemic
summer of 2020 and it led to what was
sometimes described as a national
Reckoning with systemic racism and
police violence
just this last weekend another shocking
video of police violence was released
this one showing the brutal beating of
Tyree Nichols by five police officers in
Memphis Tennessee earlier this month
Nichols screamed for his mother and did
not appear to resist he died in the
hospital following the beating the
release of that video also sparked
protests and outrage but several things
were different this time first video was
taken from police body cams and was
released by the city second unlike in
the flood killing all of the officers
were black the officers have already
been fired and charged with
second-degree murder among other charges
and even organizations like the
Fraternal organization of police which
has historically defended police
officers released a statement condemning
the actions shown in the video I will
say I read several descriptions of the
video but I was not able to watch all of
the body cam footage so before we really
get the conversation going today I just
want to go around and ask you guys did
you watch all of the video and if so
what was your reaction Catherine let's
start with you I did watch it I forced
myself to watch it I generally am not
I'm not a person who consumes
information via video I really prefer to
read about things I prefer to listen
um but it seemed important to me to
watch the whole thing and
um
you know this is a common feature of
these videos but it still was so
striking in this one the calling out for
his mother I know that a lot has been
made of it and in some ways it you know
it has almost already been cheapened or
something
um but listening to that watching that
in real time I mean my children have
probably made me weak that's what I hear
parenting does to you but it was
excruciating like just absolutely brutal
um and uh and I think that what it
captures is this feeling of of
helplessness that people feel in those
moments um and that I felt watching that
video that there is sort of an
inevitability to this type of
interaction and once you are in it
there's nothing you can do or say to
stop it from going where it's going to
go
um that that was the overwhelming
feeling that I had
um which has definitely been reinforced
by seeing more than one of these videos
over the years Nick did you watch the
video
yeah I always uh seek out uh these kinds
of uh videos because I think it's
important uh yeah and that also included
uh kind of terrorist violence uh you
know things like the Daniel Pearl
beheading thing because it's it's one
thing to read about them it's another
thing to see them this one reminded me
uh in a real sickening way of the Rodney
King beating video uh from 1991 which
kind of inaugurated this period that I
think we're still in of where uh you
know what might be called surveillance
or you know uh which is surveillance but
from underneath or from distributed
sources coming into play
um and the thing that is worth taking
away from it Beyond some of the uh you
know the the kind of really deeply uh
horrific emotional moments that
Catherine was talking about is that you
see in this and this is also true in
Rodney King which again is kind of like
an ER text for this where the police
have some somebody who is completely
incapacitated who who is not a threat to
them uh that they continue to beat and
that is you know that is where the line
clearly gets crossed um and also
um I think it's one of the places where
uh the the conversation about
de-escalating violence uh in police
encounters has you know the discussion
of that was big for a while it keeps
going missing this is the type of
incident that really puts that you know
I mean it's banal to say but it puts it
front and center yeah I did watch the
video um it is horrific I you know I
could just repeat everything that
Catherine and Nick already said I guess
the one thing I would add to it is that
uh all the officers involved have been
charged with second-degree murder and I
think maybe charged with other things
too and after watching the video that
seems totally right to me this was an
incident in which as Nick said they they
continually escalated the violence even
though uh that there was obviously no
threat to them I think anybody who
watches the this video you know there's
no way to make the argument as you
sometimes hear from police Defenders of
like oh you know they have to make a
split second decision and it's life or
death and we can't like they had many
many many opportunities to stop doing
what they were doing and at every one of
those moments chose to keep doing the
thing including the moment where they
the shoe tie yeah like
at one point another officer like walks
over and and tries to like almost like
moves one of the other cops out of the
way and looks like he's almost like he's
like trying to pull him away like hey
you know don't don't kick that guy
anymore and then the officer who has
walked over to do that proceeds to then
kick him three more times on the ground
and so it's I mean yeah it's just like
at every moment there were many many op
many many opportunities here for uh
different choices to be made and they
made the wrong choice at every one of
those opportunities and so uh yeah like
I think charging them all with murder is
absolutely appropriate in this case and
I hope Justice does uh what it does
yeah and I think that's true even if you
accept the initial version of the events
which said that the the stop started as
a reckless driving stop right even if
there was you know quite aggressive
reckless driving in in advance of this
there were opportunities to de-escalate
while this was happening Nick
um actually I just want to ask you here
this is obviously pretty awful there's
nothing to be happy about really but I
do wonder if you see any signs of
progress in the way this was handled
um the officers were fired and charged
pretty quickly after the assault right
this was I mean less than a month here
the city released the footage knowing it
would be incendiary in an effort to be
transparent do you see anything to sort
of say well at least this is being
handled better than it has been in the
past
I yeah I think and that that might
unfortunately be the limit of it which
is that you know the immediate response
from the police establishment was to
cast these guys Into the Fire
um by the same token you don't know how
much of that is just cover your ass
because you know part of well you know
part of what any kind of investigation
and any kind of trial is going to do is
going to look at were these were these
uh police acting in accordance or you
know following police procedure as
taught to them uh you know I know we're
going to talk a little bit about the
Scorpion group and everything which is
you know is a is a kind of Elite Force
within the Memphis police force Etc and
things like that but uh because going
back to Rodney King that was a big part
of the defense is that at every moment
the cops who were beating Rodney King to
uh you know a millimeter of his life
were following the actual you know
police procedures that they had been
taught and had been you know so in fact
they were following you know exact they
were following orders and things like
that and that's a big question because
these uh these instances are rare
um and the question is how much do they
reflect you know bad behavior by Rogue
cops and how much are they you know
exemplary or exemplifying what uh you
know what a system of punitive violence
you know official punitive violence uh
looks like
um the way to another way to think about
this is so you know it's it's good that
the police is not uh and the city is not
crouching you know is is not in a
defensive Crouch but they seem to be
willing to actually open this up uh in
in the year following George Floyd's
murder uh where again the police uh
hierarchy and the city were like yeah
you know what this is really awful they
did not pretend that this was you know a
standard operating procedure on that uh
there was something like 250 laws passed
um in the year after George Floyd's
death a lot having to do with certain
you know Banning choke holds and things
like that Liz Nolan Brown at reason
today has a piece up showing that most
of the popular reforms uh that were kind
of pushed or talked about in the wake of
the Floyd killing were not would not
have changed the outcome of this because
it's basically you know they didn't use
chokeholds to beat him to death uh and
things like that uh the other thing
where there is some small uh evidence of
not maybe not of progress but of change
is that cities like Portland San
Francisco Denver a number of other
places have actually worked to remove
police from enforcing traffic laws but
it also turns out that when you look at
uh you know the police databases of of
deaths at the hands of police
stunningly few uh actually involve
traffic stops so uh you know it's
something like at uh mapping police
violence in the last year there were
about 1100 uh murders at the hands of
police most of those just Justified et
cetera but only 86 of them actually stem
from traffic stops so you know there's
some progress but not much and you know
I mean I'd throw out there that the low
number of about you know a thousand
police deaths a year which has more or
less been the case since about 2015 when
these numbers started getting
um uh compiled in the wake of uh the
Michael Brown uh death in Ferguson
Missouri uh you know that might be the
lower limit when you're talking about
literally you know millions of arrests a
year hundreds probably hundreds of
millions of encounters between police
and uh and citizens or residents but
um so Catherine uh historically it has
been difficult to go after cops who
commit crimes on the job in many cases
because of specific legal protections
and public sector employment issues what
do you see as the major obstacles that
remain to punishing bad behavior by
police and what hopes if any to have a
reform yeah I was actually thinking
about this this weekend that
weirdly the strides that we've made in
checking police misbehavior
have been many of them have not had the
the intended effect but still a positive
effect so I'm thinking here about body
cams you know we I really thought I mean
absolutely really thought that there
would be an observer effect that but by
wearing body cameras
police officers would would behave
better to know that you are being
watched is to alter your behavior and
that surely the existence of the body
counts would prevent misbehavior there's
not evidence that that has happened
there have been some really good studies
looking into this question and it's hard
to know right because of course we don't
have camera evidence we don't have video
evidence from before they were wearing
body cams at the same volume and the
same quality
we also don't have a counter factual
right a world without body cams we don't
know absolutely but I think you know
people but we do have a world with cell
phones which comes pretty close to I
mean it really but I think if you had
asked me and I probably and wrote this
like I I would have assumed that there
would be a substantial change in the
kind of really really egregious Behavior
if you know you're on camera why are you
doing illegal stuff why are you doing
you know why are you doing this sort of
thing
um that has not turned out to be true
and that instead what the body cameras
have done is has been to provide
evidence in he said she said to provide
um a firm basis for prosecuting
misbehavior and also for exonerating
innocent people who you know had
evidence planted on them that kind of
thing
um it's all after the fact and so that
is why I am tempted to say the only
thing that matters is well two things
the only thing that matters in terms of
a formal reform is to end qualified
immunity we are all broken records on
this but it's an after the fact thing
right like it's when the bad thing
already happened and the question is
just what happens to the cops who did
the bad thing
and uh I think the only way to change
behavior in the long run is to have a
deeply held belief on the part of police
officers on the part of law enforcement
officers that they will be held
accountable and that has to be through a
long-standing consistent enforcement in
the courts there's oh that's the only
way because to just say hey you're not
allowed to use this chokehold
um I am very skeptical of that working
of course the other thing which ties
into what Nick was saying earlier is
just we need a world in which there are
fewer interactions with police and there
are lots of ways to achieve that world
and that's a lot of what reason magazine
does every day is like think of ways to
write the rules so that people don't
have to interact with police except for
when police will be a pretty clear
net gain uh in the in the situation
Eric uh Nichols is a black man and in
this case all of the police officers
involved all of the police officers who
did the bad thing were also black
um some have noted that this adds some
complexity to simple narratives about
individual racism and policing there's a
piece in the New York Times that said
that problems of race and policing are a
function of an entrenched police culture
of aggression and dehumanization of
black people more than of interpersonal
racism it is the system and the tactics
that Foster racism and violence they say
rather than specific racial identities
of the officers does the fact that all
of the officers involved in this beating
were black
change anything about the way we should
understand the racial implications of
police violence in general or of this
specific incident I think it does change
things a little bit but maybe not in the
obvious way and I think if anything it
actually Narrows the focus here rather
than adding complexity so let me explain
what I mean by that in a second but
first I want to point out this like
there was the CNN Headline this is a
piece written by Van Jones uh over the
weekend and it just is worth mentioning
here because the headline on it is the
police who killed Tyree Nichols were
black period but they might still have
been driven by racism period That's the
two sentence headline and it's like
you're just really trying to jam that
racism narrative in here no matter what
and I'm totally open to the idea that
there is something sort of inherently uh
there is some sort of like white
supremacist element to policing and
certainly there is historical you know
evidence that that was the case whether
that still is you know I don't know I'm
open to that argument but I think with
this situation shows you is that this
isn't really a racial problem and that
and that if if addressing policing
requires that we solve addressing the
problems with policing uh requires that
we solve racism that becomes a much more
difficult task
and so in some ways that I think that is
actually the more complicated lens
through which to view this what we learn
from this incident in which five black
cops beat a black man to death is that
the problem is they were cops there's
something that New York Times bit that
you just read there Peter is exactly
right that the problem here is something
about the training and the lack of
accountability that police officers that
the LA the training that they receive
and the lack of accountability that they
that they don't receive or that they
don't expect to see on the back end when
they engage in bad behavior that crosses
all racial lines that's not that's not a
white thing or a black thing it's not a
it's not a racism thing but the
clarifying thing here is and I think the
The Helpful thing here is that we don't
have to solve racism to fix these
problems we can address the problems
with policing by as Catherine was
talking about uh fixing qualified
immunity I think uh Liz Nolan Brown in
her piece this morning that that Nick
already mentioned also points out how
the the massive differences between the
way this was originally described this
incident in the police press report and
the what the actual footage shows so so
we can learn from that media should
learn from that and general news
consumers should learn from that not to
trust the police's first account of
these types of incidents
um and so there are things we can do in
a much more specific and focused way uh
that maybe have racial components to
them in in undoing some of these
problems with with police work in
America but uh you know it's actually
much easier I think to solve these
problems than it is to say well we have
to fix structural racism on a you know
societal level before we can expect
police to behave better
uh since this may even be to follow up
on that this may actually be uh you know
you don't want to say a blessing and
disguise or anything like that but to
the extent that it actually focuses on
police procedures it can be a clarifying
moment and a useful moment because what
happened almost immediately after George
Floyd and with the you know the way that
black lives matter and a couple of other
groups started talking about structural
racism uh you know and white supremacy
and all of that kind of stuff it really
stopped reforms like major reforms from
happening because I think ultimately
it's a bad analysis America has a white
supremacist past in certain parts and
things like that but to call you know
America in 2023 or in 2021 or whenever
uh you know a white supremacist society
and that that's the real problem and you
know these uh these you know police
murders are kind of rounding errors in
that Machinery of Oppression is not only
alienated to most people including most
minorities but it's just fundamentally
false so to the extent that this focuses
on the way police actually act why
they're called into action and what
limits should be put on all of that I
think maybe we can get to a place to you
know reduce the number of police murders
that are unjustified to zero or
something like that I will point out you
know and and this none of this is too uh
you know uh you know just wave this away
or anything but
um according to uh mapping police
violence Memphis had 25 police killings
between 2013 and 2021 25 total something
like 289 000 arrests in that period so
this is also one of those questions
where we are talking about extremely low
numbers and while the urge is always to
make these the apotheosis of something
you know in fact that's also something
that we we both need to acknowledge and
recognize nice and the fact that this is
you know a black guy being killed by
police and blacks are you know five
times more likely to be killed by police
uh than whites
um you know that that matters but that
also is not the only you know it's not
the only thing going on here so
Catherine Eric brought up training and
Nick already noted that the officers who
beat Nichols were all part of a special
unit dubbed the street crimes operation
to restore peace in our neighborhoods
operation which it turns out is an
acronym for Scorpion the Scorpion unit
was an Elite Squad of police officers
who operated in small teams with less
oversight than other cops that squad has
already been disbanded in the New York
Times former reason journalist Bradley
Balco has a pretty helpful op-ed looking
at these units with a bit of history on
a program from Detroit in the 1970s the
stop the robberies enjoy Safe Streets
program and that of course stood for
stress so Catherine what does that tell
you about the promise or Perils of
policing based on scary sounding
acronyms I was gonna say first and
foremost it tells us once again the
deepest principle of Reason journalism
which is that if your thing has acutes
the acronym acronym it is a crappy
authoritarian not just the DC thing
actually it's just the Congressional
thing yeah evil um and uh so that's
that's worth getting out of the way yeah
I mean I think I think that people
sometimes confuse
two problems and one is are police
officers who are trying to do their jobs
genuinely
um crippled by too much bureaucracy and
too many stupid rules on what they can
and can't do I think they are I think
that is that is a true problem and that
anyone who is part of any large
institution doubly so if that large
institution is the government knows that
that is true there is a bunch of dumb
stuff that cops have to do with their
time that is not benefiting the
community is not doing any of the kind
of core functions that we might expect
out of police officers and that's a
problem
the the solution is not
no oversight or less oversight of uh
particularly
the officers that are out interacting
with the community day to day that's the
wrong answer to a real problem and so I
I am sympathetic when people say like
how are cops supposed to do their jobs
when they're you know have to do so much
paperwork every time and have to you
know their their hands are tied in all
these different ways and it's it's like
yeah I fully believe you that those
systems are bad
but the answer is not create a bunch of
like Cowboys inside of a system with
dumb rules that get selective exceptions
to some of those rules
um
that takes us to this place that takes
us to
you know not because again this was not
one officer acting badly this was a team
of people who had been assembled
agreed on a series of norms and then
executed this like group action that was
horrific and that they they all looked
at each other doing it and said this is
Right This Is Us doing our jobs
um so the culture that was created
inside that unit
and inside similar units in the past is
clearly not what we want to be
encouraging
I'm like I say I I you don't have to
convince me the government agencies are
built inefficiently and are annoying to
work for and that like people can't do
the parts of their jobs that they think
are important absolutely that's true but
this is not the solution
all right so speaking of dumb government
bureaucracies with cultural problems
let's move to our next segment it's only
January but the treasury Department has
already announced that America has hit
the debt limit so I'm going to call this
segment debt men tell no Tales hitting
the debt limit is gonna set up a
showdown between President Biden who
wants to raise the debt limit with no
concessions and House Republicans who
want well some sort of spending cuts
maybe and possibly to balance the budget
within a decade but without touching
Social Security or Medicare they haven't
really clearly specified exactly which
Cuts they prefer
um the closest thing they have done to
being specific is that they've ruled out
two programs from the cuts Social
Security and Medicare after president
Trump released excuse me former
president Trump released a short video
urging Republicans not to cut old age
entitlements several high-profile
Republicans said those programs were
were off limits over the weekend Speaker
of the House Kevin McCarthy who is the
closest thing Republicans have to a
leader in the debt limit negotiations
echoed that sentiment saying that
entitlement Cuts should be taken off the
table so Eric going to start with you
here one of the arguments that critics
of the Republicans in the house are
making here is that House Republicans
are demanding that the White House
negotiate over spending cuts but the
House GOP does not appear to have a plan
or a proposal that they can all rally
behind that makes it hard to negotiate
since the other side doesn't even know
what it is that Republicans want and
since Republicans haven't actually shown
people what they want it also means that
the mass doesn't really add up on say
balancing the budget which is at least
something that has been raised by some
of the Republicans in the house so what
do you think of that criticism of House
Republicans are are liberal critics of
the House GOP right
I think they have a point and I think
it's obviously that the I mean it's
obvious that at the moment Republicans
don't have a clear plan for balancing
the budget or or even a place that
they're going to begin this negotiation
at uh but I think it's also a little bit
unfair because we do have until June
there is a there is a period of time
here in which uh to develop a plan and
to decide you know from uh looking at
polls of what your voters want and what
your what Your members in the house want
to kind of come up with a plan
um I think and like on that point I
think it's sort of hilarious that like
treasury secretary Janet Yellen has said
that we've you know we've hit the debt
limit but we're not going to actually
tip over into crisis mode until June
it's like she's basically looked around
the treasury Department and like
assessed the size and depth of the
couches in the treasury Department and
she's like yeah I'm pretty sure we can
find enough money in all these couches
to keep paying the debt limit until June
like that's we're in this Extraordinary
Measures period
um so that like I don't know the whole
thing is is a bit uh concerning because
we don't really know exactly when uh
we're going to to get into like really
serious his territory here
um but look the bottom line in all of
this is that the thing that Trump has
said and that JD Vance and other
Republicans have said in the wake of
trump releasing that video last week
about not touching Social Security
Medicare is kind of a misnomer
um anybody who says we're not going to
touch Social Security we're not going to
make any changes to Social Security what
they are really saying is there will be
cuts to Social Security in a decade
because Social Security will hit
insolvency somewhere around 2034 and
when that happens benefit Cuts will
automatically be cut across the board by
like somewhere around 20 we're not
exactly sure what it'll look like but it
is trust funds yeah
there's no world in which you don't
touch Social Security or Medicare and it
just keeps functioning the way it is now
forever
um so that the choice is Cuts later or
changes now
um and that's you know those are really
the only two options here
or actually what's most likely tax
increases later to cover virtual
everything but uh you know this is a
replay of you know things that were
going on in the Arts but uh last year
the federal government spent 6.3
trillion dollars it brought in 4.9
trillion I think to start talking about
balancing the budget in the decade and
stuff like that is and and to say this
or that is sacrosanctus to play into the
dumb Washington logic of this on the
part of the Republicans like surely they
can come up with things to cut
immediately so that we're not spending
6.2 trillion or 6.3 trillion again uh
you know Rand Paul uh you know tea party
Senator Rand Paul said uh they should
start with by looking at the defense
budget that's like a pretty good place
to go I would love to see uh you know
Republicans Cobble together I don't you
know let's say 500 billion half a
trillion dollars in spending cuts that
they can throw right in front of people
right now yeah how did how did we end I
also about wars in Iraq and Afghanistan
and the defense budget went up like
explain that to me too right like the
budget that at the very least should go
down yeah
and I also want to point out uh I I
don't know uh Peter if you agree with
this uh because you've written a lot
about budgeting this is Eric and
Catherine also weighs in too but like
this is one of the good things about
that limit debates uh you know we can
argue whether or not they're legitimate
they're moral they're effective but at
least they do present an opportunity to
actually talk about spending at a time
when very very few people seem
interested in it whatsoever all right
Catherine I want to bring you in here
with a special President Biden tweet I
thought I'd have a break this week with
Madoff nope we're gonna do it um so just
this Sunday that's yesterday
Biden tweeted Americans have paid into
their social security and Medicare every
single paycheck since they were 16 years
old I'm strengthening those programs and
if a piece of legislation lands on my
desk that wants to gut them I'll veto it
go
in
it's
that one doesn't actually get my uh you
know raised the hairs on the back of my
neck in the way that some that doesn't
step up my Malarkey detector but only
because it's so Bland right like this is
the same oatmeal that we have been being
served by politicians of both parties
about
entitlements generally Social Security
specifically the imaginary savings
account that's waiting for us the lock
box if you will and also
the idea that
um the two options are strengthen or gut
right like
why you gotta be like that my guy I know
you're out here seeing the many many
many Shades of Gray between strengthen
and gut would you say there are 50. yeah
I would say there are about 50. um and
um they're all just as unsavory as that
book I get it but
um you know
the sort of long fuse adjustments to
expected benefits are not a gutting they
are a reasonable adjustment given the
world that we live in
um and yeah I mean I think you know even
I your friendly neighborhood Anarchist
doesn't think it would be it would sort
of meet the demands of fairness to end
Social Security tomorrow just be like
sorry jerks no checks for you like
people have planned their lives around
this this is the same thing that we talk
about a lot
with regular regulatory uncertainty with
respect to all kinds of like major
decisions that businesses make that
individuals make
um at the same time
it is entirely wholly morally defensible
to scale back some benefits absolutely
it is and and in fact
when you uh you know when you think
about it in the bigger picture it's
required because otherwise we are just
punishing future Generations we are you
know bringing about all the things that
Eric described where's the uh where's
the youth Quake on this where you know
you guys are younger than me I I'm I'm
starting to actually believe that I'm
going to receive Social Security
um I was always assuming that it would
shut right before I was about to tap
into it but I mean if you're under 45
why aren't you [__] in the streets
over you know the ludicrous things
you're going to maintain the security uh
no I mean I think Nick Nick has said
this just a few months ago I think on
this same podcast about like how we're
gonna have this uh generational Warfare
is going to be like the theme of the
next few years or something and uh like
yeah I think that's probably right as we
get closer and closer to this deadline I
think more people will become aware of
uh of just how screwed Social Security
is for the long run
um and so yeah like if you're younger
than I'm 35 right now I have very low
expectations that I'll receive anything
from Social Security
um I would just like that like if the
government just gave me back the taxes
I'd paid into it right now I would say
great done I don't even we won't even
fight over interest just give me the
principle that I just pretend this never
happens Pretend This Never Happened and
we'll be done and I'm I'll be out
forever like good I would take that deal
uh but that Deal's not gonna happen
either obviously would you take just
would you take no no paying in anything
no I would want the money back and just
walk away that I've already put it
there's the problem that would be a
negotiation obviously but that
negotiation isn't going to happen
because what's really going to happen
here is the first thing that's going to
happen is they're going to raise the cap
on the payroll tax to make rich people
pay more into Social Security right
which you can easily sell as we're gonna
make sure the rich pay more so that
everybody gets benefits blah blah blah
easy enough then you're gonna do some
sort of means testing that will allow
you to to curtail benefits to the rich
as well and then that's gonna you know
be sold along the same sort of populist
political lines but even that this is
this is what Brian Riedel who's a former
Sen Senate budget staffer and now a
senior fellow at the Manhattan Institute
and crunches all these numbers so he's
done this work it's not just coming out
of my brain but you know those two
things alone don't get you to where you
need to go to fix this problem so then
you have to start looking at things that
would be more politically difficult you
have to start looking at like increasing
the payroll tax rate which obviously
hits all workers and people will be
angry about that uh you have to look at
things like maybe some sort of uh vat
tax or something like that just to shore
up Social Security like there there will
be pain here for everyone this is not a
problem that you can get out of just by
saying we will tax the rich and we will
take away their social security which is
the first thing people will try to do
I think the thing that stood out to me
about that Biden tweet is that it plays
into this very common idea that you paid
in and you earned it and that therefore
Social Security is yours and that you
have some sort of uh something like a
legal claim to it when in fact the
opposite is true uh for in two different
ways one is the amount that you are
likely to get out most people will get
up far more than they paid in which is
why there is a shortfall if you pay in
less than you get out then that doesn't
work over the long run the other thing
is that legally speaking you have no
right to that money and so when the with
where the government takes it from you
in tax form there they have absolutely
no legal obligation to set it aside and
make sure that you get it again at the
end of your life it is a transfer
program from young to old not a savings
program and the political rhetoric even
if it doesn't explicitly say this is a
savings program and you have some legal
right to this it often sort of works
from the application or the assumption
that people have that oh that's my money
it's not the government took it from you
and now it is the government's money
and I think that's that drives a huge
amount of misunderstanding uh about
entitlements and about how they work
okay so we are gonna we're gonna go to
the next uh segment here the reader
question but before that we're gonna pay
some bills with an advertisement this
show is sponsored by betterhelp
when you feel like yourself you can do
great things but sometimes life is hard
you may feel overwhelmed you may feel
like you're in another room and you just
can't quite heal your hear yourself
working with a therapist can get you
closer to the best version of you
because when you feel empowered you're
more prepared to take on everything life
throws at you therapy can help it can
teach coping skills it can Empower you
to take control of your feelings it's
for everyone in all walks of life if
you're thinking of giving therapy a try
better help is a great option it's
convenient flexible affordable and
entirely online just fill out a brief
questionnaire get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapists
anytime for no additional charge if you
want to live a more empowered life
therapy can get you there
visit betterhelp.com Roundtable today to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp.com Roundtable
all right so this week's listener
question is about legalizing drugs and
it comes from listener Griffin we're
going to call this segment pulling the
drug out from under us hello Roundtable
crew
hello Roundtable crew I am a lawyer who
represents clients in the Cannabis
industry there is a prevailing thought
that we can end the war on drugs by
legalizing them
well okay but this is wrong this is
wrong uh says Griffin every state with
legal cannabis has Byzantine regulations
and licensing requirements that end up
excluding people unless they have lots
of money or get into bed with people who
have lots of money these people often
open illegal businesses and the
government inevitably either continues
enforcement against these illegal
businesses or as in the case of
California does virtually nothing and
allows the illegal Market to Fester at
the expense of all the folks who
undertook the expense of getting
licensed obviously complete deregulation
would eliminate enforcement altogether
but realistically that's not going to
happen given all of that what does the
Roundtable think the solution is to
ending the War on Drugs Nick let's start
with you what about the problem of like
we are if if drugs are legalized uh
practically speaking we are going to
have some amount of Taxation and
regulation yeah and therefore what do we
do about that
uh I don't know let's look to uh you
know the uh markets for uh selling beer
wine and alcohol
um and somehow you know those managed to
get by you don't hear Too Many people uh
complaining that they can't set up
corner bodegas and sell beer uh in them
and things like that you know and the
first thing to recognize too is you know
uh California has made a mess of uh
marijuana legalization other states have
done better such as Colorado New York is
in the in the process of screwing up
legalization royally but the federal
government has not done anything yet so
we still have a long way to go in that
and I would argue that if you actually
descheduled or legalized marijuana at
the national level and all of the
implications of that including banking
Etc uh we would we'd be working in a
very different circumstance which
wouldn't be without problems but there
would be many fewer than there are
Catherine what do we do about the fact
that even in a legal world a world of
legal drugs there will still be
regulations still be taxes and that will
create incentives for black markets
um
I actually I thought Eric might like
jump in here and uh start waving his
arms around because he's written some
really great stuff on how our tax and
regulated markets for alcohol are pretty
messed up actually like it's Nick is
absolutely right to say the the corner
beer Bodega situation is not um is not
the pressing issue but
um but I do think you know this is one
reason that I worry about the
I think quite defensively libertarian
approach to okay you know the menarchist
approaching which you say okay we're
gonna have to fund the state somehow
um we're gonna have to have some kind of
taxes let's do consumption taxes and
maybe even let's do consumption taxes
where we use those taxes to nudge
Behavior because after all we want to
encourage good things and discourage bad
things and
um it's it's all fine as far as it goes
but you it takes you straight to
oh we have a pre-existing habitual Black
Market in this thing it's going to it's
going to live on it's gonna you know
carry all of the downsides of the black
market into the into the world in which
there is there is legalization and you
know I think that actually the parallel
in many ways is
um is opiates right it's Pharmaceuticals
where
those are legal but they are so
regulated so aggressively policed that
um we have managed to create a new drug
crisis out of out of nothing and of
course for all of this read Jacob sullum
um
by trying to pull these levers of what
we think people should and shouldn't do
and what we think they should and
shouldn't consume
so yes I mean are in fact very
specifically the last 25 years we have
seen increased regulation of opiates and
that has coincided with and arguably
helped fuel the opioids crisis as uh
synthetic versions that are much more
dangerous for people have flooded the
market exactly Eric
Eric how do you think about this
question yeah I think about it uh in in
along the lines of like what happened
after prohibition right it's very
similar
um and there are states there was a wide
range of different rules that we that we
exited prohibition with and uh States
that had bad rules rules that were not
very competitive and didn't allow for
markets to operate as uh fully as as
they should for the the same
Pennsylvania I mean Pennsylvania
obviously is one of the famous examples
Mississippi Mississippi didn't repeal
prohibition many many states and and
those rules once they were put in place
whenever the repeal came along uh those
rules were then difficult to change and
in some cases lasted for decades even
though people were very aware of how bad
they were and so yeah sure use
Pennsylvania is the famous example here
right there were there were beer
distributor licenses in Pennsylvania and
those things were incredibly valuable
they were so valuable that they created
this own kind of like political economy
to maintain this bizarre system where
you couldn't buy six packs of beer you
had to buy cases of beer this is just
one example of the many weird rules that
Pennsylvania had but the beer
distributors the people who had that
small number of licenses were for
decades one of the most powerful and
vocal groups in the state capitol
against liberalizing the rules any
further in Pennsylvania because they
didn't want the competition they didn't
want grocery stores to sell beer they
didn't want other places to be able to
sell six packs and compete with them and
so you ended up with I think exactly
what the what the questionnaire here is
asking which is like you end up with a
government it's not prohibition anymore
obviously it's better than that but you
end up with these government granted
privileges that create their own kind of
special interests that then perpetuate
what is uh you know better than a war on
drugs or prohibition but obviously not
an ideal situation either
the first time I ever got drunk was off
of a case of Yingling purchased in
Allegheny County
just outside of Pittsburgh no my
congratulations to you my condolences to
you I'm not sure what the response to
that is the one of the best beers
America's America's oldest so I I think
people just uh really underrate I like I
totally take the point of this of this
question I think this is a good question
for like how to think about legalization
efforts but I do think people uh
misunderstand what prohibition did
Prohibition uh or sort of what the end
of prohibition did I should say the end
of prohibition lifted the federal rules
but it left in place many many many
quite restrictive State rules some of
which are still on the books or or kind
of uh the legacy of them is still on the
books today and are still affecting how
people can purchase alcohol at the same
time the other thing that prohibition
the the end of prohibition did was it
pretty much stopped people stopped gangs
from murdering each other over alcohol
and this is this is to me like in some
ways the most important thing right like
I I would really like there to be nice
orderly uh minimally regulated markets
for drugs that would be great if people
could make money off of this stuff if we
could you know have uh if we could you
know have some sort of safety uh regime
where like you can where this stuff is
public right where you can sort of get
it in in safe environments all of that
but the main thing that I want is for
gangs to stop shooting each other over
drugs and that happened a lot over
alcohol during prohibition for really
obvious reasons and basically as soon as
prohibition was lifted that ended and
that's what I want to see over and that
like even if even if what is left is a
crappy highly regulated market in which
it's hard to sort of set up shop in
which the rules are difficult in which
there are still some illegal outposts if
what we can do is end the the the
violence that is associated with the
black market then that's a huge step and
it's worth doing it even if the the next
Air if the next phase of Regulation is a
total mess okay so we are good we have
just a couple of minutes left here
before we get to our recommendations and
I want to do a lightning round uh a
segment on arming Ukraine that I'm going
to call thank you sir may I have another
the United States Germany the UK uh
other Western Nations have said in the
past month or so we call in an airstrike
on Peter I like it I don't like it that
I like it but I like it so we're sending
tanks to Ukraine to Aid the war in
Russia and some reports also indicate
that the Pentagon is under heavy
pressure to start sending F-16 fighter
jets as well let's do a lightning round
around the panel what's your reaction to
the escalation of Western Arms being
supplied to Ukraine is this good bad
complicated or something else Nick let's
start with you
ugh it's complicated and uh it's bad
that we're doing it I don't think this
is the uh United States fight uh we
should support a free Ukraine uh and we
should not be sending you know tanks
planes and uh advisors who are already
entering the country there by setting up
a possibility of us being fully
embroiled yeah I think I agree with that
it's complicated skewing towards bad
um I I at some point I think we're just
in a war with Russia and it's like
that's a very uncomfortable situation to
find yourself so you know and I don't
know who gets to make that decision and
NATO and the and the US don't
necessarily control the decision of when
are we at war with Russia uh Russia has
a pretty big say in that and you know uh
the American government does certainly
certainly which doesn't seem to be
really uh right now
for more funding for supplying arms is
that is that Congress should at some
Point either say we are at war with
Russia and declare war on behalf of
Ukraine or congress should say we are
not at war with Russia and therefore we
will you know draw some lines around
what we are willing to do
um and in the absence of that it's a
it's a pretty fraught and kind of
terrifying situation
Catherine tanks uh F-16 fighter jets
what do you think I mean I just want a
world where there's a free and
transparent Market in fighter jets like
that's really the the dream you know
um and I I recognize that's a little bit
flip but also you know of course of
course in the world that we actually
live in it is inevitable that
um War making Machinery will be
um controlled and wielded by governments
um but it needn't be right like there's
a theoretical World in which the sale of
a tank is a neutral commercial act and
if Ukraine can pay for tanks they are
welcome to buy them from us and by us I
mean not the nation which shouldn't be
producing anything but like tanks R Us I
don't know who makes tanks
um
a thousand neocons just like wept in my
in my uh you know my lessons
um failing that I agree with Nick and
Eric that we
the danger to me is not will we
overextend in any kind of particular
moment but that
you know Eric's point that at some point
if Russia decides the things we did our
war they can decide that unilaterally
like I know we want Congress to Congress
it up but like
if they attack us if Russia attacks the
United States because it decides we are
already at War
then we're at War
um and I sure would not like that to be
the case um as as we have said many
times on this podcast the cause of the
ukrainians is just that doesn't make it
our cause we live in a world in which uh
I believe it was Congress or some
regulatory agency decided that
PlayStations I can't remember whether it
was the PS2 or the PS3 where I'm pretty
sure it was the PS3 we're actually so
powerful that they constituted National
Security protected items and therefore
could not be shipped to China or
something like that so I I really feel
like if we can't even deregulate and
sort of take PlayStations out of the out
of the realm of National Security tanks
are probably uh tanks and fighter jets
are probably not going to be sold on the
open world can dream can't she
yes you can um speaking of video games
and video game systems let's go to our
final segment what you what you've been
consuming reading watching
Etc Eric let's start with you this is
tough because I was I was going to talk
about the peripheral and Andor both of
which I just finally finished but I see
that people have already talked about
them on this show Peter has them both
you can talk about so shows we're both
wonderful you should watch them also
this is a reminder to people who are
listening that you can check out
reason.com backslash The Round the
reason Roundtable recommendations to
find like all the recommendations from
all past episodes which is helpful if
you're not here every week and you don't
know what people have talked about
necessarily
um so instead I will mention uh an album
that I was listening to this morning on
the way here uh that is fantastic uh
this is uh Kaylee goldsworthy is uh the
artist's name she's like been in a
number of bands or sort of like a
touring musician with a bunch of uh punk
bands that I'm a fan of uh and now she's
put out actually back in October put out
her first uh LP learning to be happy and
it's like it's sort of like if you if
you like the rockier elements of Taylor
Swift's Red album which I am a huge fan
of and but but you wish it was like it
sounded a little bit more like Jimmy
world that's kind of where she's at
um she's a Philly musician and anyway
it's a really cool album I won't go on
too long about it but I think it's uh I
think it's like an interesting thing to
listen to
um and uh the the I guess interesting
political element to this is that uh for
the first week I think that it was out
in October she had 100 of the proceeds
from her album went to uh Planned
Parenthood
um in protest of uh the the Supreme
Court decision last year so for our
listeners who are more on the pro-choice
side of things I think maybe there's
another element there to listen to I'll
just recommend like two tracks um losing
my mind and over ambitious are both uh
really fantastic like pop Punky but with
like a little tinge of country kind of
element to them as well uh cool stuff
learning to be happy by Kaylee
goldsworthy
I have not heard of her but Taylor Swift
meets Jimmy Eat World is possibly the
most elder Millennial thing I can
imagine just like in any realm
um Nick what do you have for us this
week
uh yeah I read uh Daniel axt akst uh War
by other means the pacifists of the
greatest generation of revolutionized
resistance it's a incredibly Rich
history of the pacifist movement leading
to a study of conscientious objectors
during World War II uh the main figures
are David Dellinger who ended up being
part of the Chicago 7 trial uh who was a
CEO during World War II Dorothy Day
Dwight McDonald and Baird Rustin who was
uh instrumental in the Civil Rights
Movement this is uh an incredible
alternative history I mean it's it's not
a counter factual or anything of it it's
just something that doesn't get
discussed very much and among other
things it um it it talks about how
religion organized religion in the
interwar period and and for a bit after
skewed left Progressive in a way that's
fascinating but the
um the push to kind of protest the draft
in World War II is amazing because these
These are people who to the extent that
they had an economics they tended to
either be uh socialist or communalist in
a way that is not you know certainly a
post-war libertarian sensibility but
some of them particularly Dorothy Day
who uh who um was big in the Catholic
Worker movement and random publication
uh with that title called themselves
libertarian because they were in favor
of increased Liberty and autonomy for
individuals so it's just it's it really
uh scrambles the categories of politics
that we think about uh you know
post-world War II or looking backwards
from today so I highly recommend War by
other means by Daniel acts who has
written for a reason at various points
and is uh a really excellent writer
great historian and uh well
I uh Unearthed a book from my sundoku
pile which is a great Japanese word that
we should all know which is the books
that you bought intending to read and
then let pile up
um and uh it is
um William mccaskill's what we owe the
future which is has been analyzed to
death including quite ably by reason's
own Ron Bailey in our Pages
um it is the case for long-termism
essentially
um the uh
now
um maligned uh now controversial I don't
know effective altruist kind of approach
to thinking about
um how much how much we should factor in
future Generations uh in our kind of
moral calculus uh you know in our
day-to-day lives in our public policy
making
and despite having consumed a lot of
commentary about this book
um I
found it to be better than I expected
and I had actually quite high
expectations for it um so the the kind
of prose itself is wonderful very very
readable very appealing
um when the book gets gimmicky as it
does in a couple places you know there's
Pages upon pages of like little printed
out stick figures to try and emphasize
to you how many people are in the future
compared with how many people are now
that kind of thing
um the gimmick almost always lands and
it's like the big splash page at the end
of Watchmen when the squid monster
finally takes over New York just like
that except for with stick figures about
moral calculations but other than that
yes exactly the same
um I mean actually yes exactly the same
like it is it is in fact like a
philosophical treatment of the squid
monster that is future generations and
whether or not they should bring us
together to you know be better
and you know I think as a matter of
actual practice the long-term Mists who
are out here doing stuff
it's it's kind of collapsed unto itself
right so the cool thing about effective
altruism was like let's be serious let's
reckon with ourselves about the fact
that a lot of what we think of as
philanthropy is self-indulgent and not
very effective not very efficient
um let's try to eliminate some of that
and do things that matter
the long-termest approach
undid that because then you just go back
to your priors oh I think climate change
matters so let's work on that I think
social justice matters so let's work on
that I think
um you know the path that AI takes is
the only thing that matters so let's
work on that
um but this book made me less snarkily
judgmental about that approach it made
me uh more open to the idea that there
are some genuine conclusions to be
reached and not just a new exciting way
of justifying your prayers so um William
mccaskill is what we owe the future
I am not the first nor will I be the
last to recommend this book it has made
the rounds but it is quite good
Catherine thank you for bringing up
monsters the apocalypse and being the
last because that makes a good segue for
me to talk about the show I've been
watching The Last of Us the new
post-apocalyptic Zombie series on HBO
it's based on a 2013 video game that is
among the very best video games I have
ever played the series third episode
aired this weekend and and I have to say
it is a borderline Masterpiece an
expansion and enrichment of a little
plot Point found in the game that just
works wonderfully on screen and really
hit me pretty hard as I watched it last
night the uh this particular episode
Stars the great Nick Offerman as an
anti-government paranoid conspiracy
obsessed survivalist gun nut bearded guy
living in a homemade Suburban bunker
where I assume he also has a complete
collection of issues of Reason magazine
so he's like set up traps and
surveillance around his house to fend
off Raiders infected zombie types and
one day a he catches another guy in the
Trap importantly another middle-aged
bearded guy
but instead of killing him or sending
him on his way he invites this other guy
into his home for a meal and then over
time they fall in love
and they live out a complete life over
decades in their little Suburban bunker
home with its American flag and their
guns and their good wine and their
arguments about like how many guns they
really need and whether it's appropriate
to believe that the government is
actually a bunch of authoritarian Nazis
or not which in the show they're
definitely really kind of are and as
they live their lives the zombie
apocalypse just sort of proceeds around
them
it's incredibly ambitious incredibly
moving and it reminded me a little bit
of one of the all-time great episodes of
genre TV the Inner Light from Star Trek
the Next Generation where Picard lives a
complete life in the memory of a Dying
civilization it's just small and
specific and well observed and deeply
Humane and to my mind it is the first
truly great TV or film project I have
seen in 2023 strongly recommend it
that's the last of us airing now on HBO
before we go Nick I just want to ask you
do you have anything to share to tease
to preview for our listeners
yeah uh a week from today on Monday uh
February 6. uh we have a reason
Speakeasy a live taping of the reason
interview podcast in Midtown Manhattan
uh the guest is Kat Rosenfield who's uh
new mystery novel is out you must
remember this which Catherine talked up
a couple of weeks ago and it's fantastic
she's also going to be talking about
some of the pieces that she wrote for
reason about things like cultural
appropriation or silencing oneself in
the uh in the face of uh kind of woke or
politically correct attacks on same uh
you can go to reason.com events
to get details tickets are ten dollars
that includes beer wine soda and food uh
the reasons Speak Easy on Monday
February 6th all right that's it for
this week remember that if you like what
you hear you can support us at
reason.com donate that's reason.com
donate thank you for listening everyone
the round table will return in
Thunderball
[Music]
bye